[Music]
we hope you're having a very Merry
Christmas Eve we have lots of goodies in
store for you today including a trip
down memory lane from our live show in
Dallas to the hair-raising haunted house
experience at Jesse and I had and Juan
fulfilling his childhood dreams at the
MLB all-star game we're taking a look
back at some of the most fun moments of
the year including a special Christmas
treat Greg Jesse and Juan head to New
York City's famous FAO Schwarz toy store
we have a lot to cover but first each of
us had a lot of memorable moments this
year so our team put together some
individual highlights of the five of us
I'm gonna go first
watch this Kevin what about Kevin that
was that commercial break flop and I'm
so sorry I'm gonna get a fired again the
scar that I have is from I fell off the
three week just asked me if I was
actually wearing heels because I'm so
short but we were told to wear our is
that better we framed up I just want to
make sure everybody knows at home Dana
is actually wearing heels
she's even sure
Dana's corny jokes here we go which
letter is the coolest okay what do you
call a running turkey what do you call a
short court trial show that's right I
know we got to go for a pile of her
charts it's a great chart and I send it
to everyone this morning so that they
could at 7:00 in the morning you get
like eight charts from Dana let me tell
you about Jasper Jasper Jasper's
birthday Jasper Jasper Jasper Jasper
Jasper Jasper Jasper Jasper Jasper
Jasper Jasper Jasper Jasper D Jasper
Jasper Jasper Jasper chasing people
around with a reptile even going into
the wall you had a wild year in there a
lot highlights a lot of low lights ah by
the way those aren't jokes those are
riddles oh do you want me to change it
Corey riddle this would be corny riddles
but are you amazed how often you say
Jasper now I am a little amazed that we
just did this we just did a Jasper
intervention I can't believe how many
days I take off and who works on the
show doesn't like watching you again by
the way I don't think that they're bad i
think that i like i would call them
jokes because they make me laugh yeah
it's a joke is different than a riddle
and that's a riddle but corny jokes
works a lot better than a corny riddle
at all exactly tell you something about
your height I mean first of all that's a
fantastic thing because you would make a
great professional snowboarder or a
gymnast
my oldest daughter reached a milestone
this year because she's now Dana plus
three Wow mm-hmm UFO I could do with
three extra inches of height thank God
my mom my mom was I think 411 but you
never really noticed it well if you're
four
she say you're five foot yeah but in a
cheat in but people short people have
yeah they're larger-than-life what I'm
really looking forward to is this next
round up we have some really
entertaining stuff take a look at Jess
tonight you'll be in this Jesse there we
go get it locked in civilization started
going downhill and I joined the five
slim jims weapon yes and lots of books
to read John Fund had a piece of
national review today I read that Andrew
McCarthy had a great piece of the
National after Tucker Jesse and Ann
Coulter's what's so funny you've seen my
bed Stan I think we should use more
movie clips in the show it's a really
good way if like you're not funny enough
you get the audience to laugh a little
bit more Jesse you're the king of what
about ISM man I'm thinking oh good one
for this this is what I call a what
about ISM scandal here's some what about
ISM one you came to the right person
about what about is about
and then lastly stop talking about your
hair I have a new hairstyle if anybody
can notice to the side the side it's a
little different I feel like I'm
considered like a metrosexual reason so
I was thinking how would i look with
hair like that did we have there it's
the same you know my mother told me to
stop talking about my hair wore that
insult Greg I was severely bullied as a
child and you know it was my
intelligence
I've never bullied I've always been
bullied or so at a touch thing one has
been exhibiting some signs of Trump
derangement syndrome
he's extremely short he's extremely
short believed they didn't like show
your jackets I love your jackets you
wear the lightest most beautiful jacket
yeah we'll do that next time
Liberace of Fox News anyway you know you
but the big star of course is your mom's
mom tax yes we should do the whole show
that one I think we should make it a lot
easier for the rest of us that's true
yes be even easier than Facebook Friday
yeah you know your mom gave me that
Trump countdown clock
yes it's speeded up I love having you
here so well thank you very much we get
a real treat
here's once guess what and guess what
guess what because guess what guess what
take a look at my grandkids folks
Eli starting third grade the girls are
off to first grade I brought back some
pictures of Raffy and Morgan here's
their magic moment exchanging rings with
father CJ yeah that's me 40 years ago
putting my wedding cake party time time
for one more thing these are the dog
days of summer big boys cry to it folks
I'm all shook up Saturday it was girls
gone wild in DC talk about jumping out
of the frying pan and into the fire
I true Democrats Democrats aren't the
ones to blame oh come on come on come on
come on the couch oh come on but anyway
the larger point took time which I'm
right that's always true optimism swirl
you have the peace pendulum with it you
you want to blame
what is the Democratic platform we
change our memories you all boned down
the Fed and then then well that's
interesting cuz the answer is b11
do I get a little more respect having
won both the supermarket know what I
realize you're one more thing intros are
like what the local newscaster does you
left out the I don't know what's going
on at this table tell you that was
that's a lot of fun to see because it's
like self revelatory yeah guess what it
kind of made funny you show and picture
your family but I love how much you love
your family well it's that's wonderful I
mean you talk about them and you really
give people a glimpse inside because
they think that you're the worst person
on the planet realize that you are
deeply connected and the fact that you
have raised Republicans the funny part
about this is it's like what did they
think I was born like without a family
what is that that could be any year yeah
right I do it on expressing it's
spreading you know you it because you
keep doing now everybody's doing it you
hear it everywhere well yes we you must
watch a lot of TV I do I do
TV to do and we're gonna have a chance
now to go down
greg's why remain watch this it's all
about bowels and she circled the earth
and a gravy boat dana perino
and she snorkels with a macaroni and she
skis in a sugar bolt and a paperclip is
her trombone is that his staple is her
balance beam I got my bread bear I'm
gonna watch it York special coverage
holding the bear
means everything one more thing cuz it
one more thing the green food here in
the DC bureau is not good
knitted glue Dobbs a body suit on the
weekends me and Lou Dobbs will go to the
park we use our own body weight as
resistance training horn to be wild the
life and times of Lou Dobbs this book is
doing great by the way if you haven't
purchased it yet you haven't bought my
book you're dead to me it's the Gutfeld
monologues I got a gift for every one of
you and I forgot to sign them I'll be
there with my book and then you can buy
the book as it will change your life now
use hers so anyway I'm gonna be a Dallas
Fort Worth Texas it's time for this
hamster is great you know what animal is
really great you can define your year as
animals are great and your book yeah but
is it my book and jobs jobs my book and
animals what else do you need deal
weekend its animal that if I invent one
thing and no one ever remembers anything
else its animals are great it's pretty
good what happened what happened with
Brett Baier saying Captain Kangaroo
brought he was wrong he was right I
looked it up kangaroo captain kangaroo
sang an entirely different song and
ironically his name's Bear but he
doesn't know much about animals that you
found on your book tour to bring this
full circle little kids that watch the
five they love to watch one more thing
they love that animal because they if
you have what if you just have at one
little animal thing or one yelling thing
like somebody acting really silly kids
like it it's like didn't you remember
when you watch the show as a kid and you
liked it but you didn't really know what
was going on for the kids like this
sweater with that Santa on a unicorn do
you keep it here at the office and every
year this has been sitting on a shelf
for like 365 days in Holland Erised
what did you have at Hollander I know I
don't know and I does kind of smell well
that's that's when you take it's an old
word for tailoring here's my here's my
relationship to you great yes when when
I go out into the rest of the Fox world
right
I say loo don't complain to me and then
if I go to DC the DC bureau I say Bret
look this is and Greg not me come up to
me and say don't you think he's making
fun I said no good fun watch Kennedy oh
no show them well I'm just watching the
fireworks with a basket of popcorn here
this is canard Depardieu well that's a
great name thank you by the way I like
it
durable oh he's so sweet it looks like
Jesse what do you say you want the
president 2020 another sell my foot I
was kicking a shark enough things I have
this vision of robert muller like a
painter just standing in front of his
canvas going I want a man artist and you
never really know when it's done you hit
the nail on the head Miranda Charlotte
sameen Miranda is for your Miranda I am
Charlotte Western Europe needs Destiny's
Child Bills Bills Bills hmm my mom
worked for the phone company I told her
I was going to spend the night at a
friend's house but I really went to the
Republican convention I know I've told
you this before if I ever I'm in a bad
mood all I do is go to youtube and watch
crying Hillary supporters from election
night
I love Kennedy's imitate did you hear
her do Bernie Sanders yes that's great
good but you needs more than one percent
this is a drink called the Hillary
celebrate they smash blackberries some
lion because it's got to be a little bit
bitter tequila to get you hammered to
help you break that glass ceiling
Kennedy you're always good for a few
laughs Oh bless your bones yeah you know
you're funny
it's an inside joke there's an anchor
that actually went up to Kennedy and
said you know you're funny for a broad
for a broad yeah that's what he said
glue jobs can you believe this is better
you know those shows that used to do
flashback episodes I hated that but this
is better
flashback episode sometimes when you
have like I just like flashbacks
whatever happened to that chick is that
chick okay that little baby the duckling
the duckling oddly enough change species
and blossomed into a beautiful swan what
they become swans is what you here for
like when you're out and about in the
world but what do people ask you about
the five they always ask about Juan and
like what are you guys the one get away
Juan probably feels very exasperated but
I had when I was filling in for you the
other night at the Loreal woman of worth
ceremony oh you backed out of that Dana
know said you got to look out for one
he's my guy I watch Fox and I watched
the five for Juan so you know they they
always want to know by the way what has
a question you can't treat alcohol on TV
but you made that amazing thing but did
it taste good it was fantastic
yes I've got one called the Sweet
Chariot also you can drink in commercial
breaks I do oh yeah if I didn't mention
for your Scott Adams what
I can't believe you guys seem how the
producers yes the best of the worst if
it's the best of times what's the worst
of times but actually it's always the
best of times on the five that would be
a good lead for a book which one I don't
know please don't write another book